- [Narrator] This UCSD-TV program
is presented by University
of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest programs.
(soft piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large brained,
long the master of fire,
tools and language.
But still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly, we hand down knowledge,
we empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from
our shared understanding
of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are
and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(soft piano music)
- So I will discuss today
the relation between
inflammation and metabolism
and metabolic homeostasis
and disease susceptibility.
So inflammation is a protective response
to a variety of challenges
that we may experience
including infection and injury
and various types of tissue stress
and malfunctions and all the
things that can go wrong.
All of them can induce
an inflammatory response
that are meant to be protective.
Depending on the type of
challenge that we experience
there's different physiological
or intended purpose of the responses
such as host defense from infection,
tissue repair response
or restoration of a normal
state of the tissues.
What is very interesting
about inflammation
and very clinically important
is that all these different
pathways to inflammation
can result in a variety
of pathological sequelae
including autoimmune diseases, sepsis,
fibrotic diseases, tumor growth
and a variety of diseases of homeostasis
that are becoming more and more common
in modern lifestyles.
To give a very, very simplified
summary of inflammation,
of inflammatory pathway
when inducers of inflammation
such as pathogens
or tissue damage are encountered,
cells in our bodies, such as macrophages
and epithelial cells and so on
detect these inducers
and produce various inflammatory mediators
including cytokines
that some of them were mentioned already.
And what these mediators do
is they act on every tissue in the body
and they change some
functional characteristics
that intend to either cause elimination
of whatever caused inflammation
or adaptation to the
presence of these conditions.
And why inflammation is so
broadly associated with diseases,
very symbolically it
could be summarized here.
So for every trait,
including defense traits,
there are benefits and costs.
For defenses the costs are
particularly pronounced
and the traits would be
evolutionarily stable
if the benefits are higher than the costs.
Anything in this green
part of the triangle
would be for potentially
evolutionarily stable
and everything here would be unstable.
The problem is that in the case of traits
that can provide very high benefits,
such as survival,
the acceptable cost can also be very high.
That leads to this type of picture
where the part of this upper triangle,
that's on the right side,
where benefits can still outweigh the cost
but in terms of the
absolute value of the cost
this would be already,
from the patient perspective at least
and the doctor's perspective,
this would be already in the disease zone.
This would be conditions
that we would experience
as something that is
definitely not well-being
and doctors would diagnose
as being various types of pathological
or disease conditions,
even though they still
provide more benefit
than the cost.
What we're interested in
is in the biology of
this upper-right corner
where the high benefits are
associated with very high costs
and where we're basically
on the edge of the chaos,
so a transition into
the pathological states
that can be potentially lethal.
This type of biology deals with
not just common conditions,
like mild infections or mild anomalies,
but it has to do with
essentially biology of survival,
what are the kinds of
mechanisms that are employed
by our system, by our organism,
in order to survive critical conditions,
the ones that are just
one step away from death.
This is just, in a very
schematic way, summarized here.
So if we consider this
type of disease tree
there are many conditions
that we are one step away from health,
these are various common, mild illnesses.
These are conditions that make you
go to see your primary care physician.
If there are complications
of these conditions
you get referred to some
internal medicine specialist.
These are more complex diseases,
but you can still recover
and go back to health
and in severe cases
you can get into this
critical illness state
when you get into ICU
and you still can recover from here
and in this critical illness state
which is conditions
like sepsis, pneumonia,
heart attack, brain damage and so forth,
in these conditions you are one step away
from these three proximal mechanisms
that lead directly to death
and these are points of no-return
which is respiratory failure,
cardiovascular failure
or damage to the brain areas
that control respiration
and cardiovascular function.
So we're interested in what happens here.
What kind of mechanisms may be evolved
to prevent this transition
into this point of no return.
The case I will discuss today
has to do with this very enigmatic
and very interesting and
very familiar to everyone
set of conditions known
as sickness behaviors.
This is something everybody
in this room experiences
when you have the flu or any
other type of severe infection
or other types of acute illness.
We all experience this set of conditions,
such as loss of appetite,
social withdrawal, fatigue,
sleepiness and so on and so forth.
So these are all serotypic conditions
that are associated with acute illness,
most commonly with acute infections,
so flu symptoms would
all be in that category.
The biology of sickness behavior
has not been really well understood
although there were early studies
that demonstrated that sickness behavior
is not just a consequence
of the system being
destroyed by a pathogen,
but rather these are motivated
behaviors, in other words,
they are intended by the
organism for some reason.
There's been many speculations
whether various aspects
of sickness behavior,
perhaps help the immune
system to fight the infection
or maybe there's some other
way that they may contribute
to dealing with acute illness.
So we were interested in investigating
aspects of acute illness,
including loss of appetite
and change in sleeping patterns
and how they may contribute to survival,
to survival of the acute illness.
So there are two ways that
we can survive an infection
or any other challenge for that matter.
We can either resist it,
so in the case of infection,
normally we would be in this state
where we are healthy
and there's a negligible pathogen load.
As we get infected an pathogens expand
we can become ill, as
indicated by this position.
From here we can either go back to health
by getting rid of pathogens
which is the role of the immune system
and this is referred to as
a resistance to disease.
Or we can adapt to the
presence of the pathogen
and go back to the healthy state
despite microbial load
and this would referred to
as increased tolerance to infection,
or tolerance to damage.
There are two ways that
pathogens cause damage,
one is directly through
tissue destruction,
through toxins, virulence
factors and so forth.
The second more common way
that infections cause illness
is due to damage by the
inflammation caused by infection.
And so we were interested in figuring out
whether sickness behaviors
provide benefit, first of all,
secondly whether they provide benefit
because they promote immune function
and resistance to infection
or whether they provide benefit
by promoting tissue protection
and tolerance to inflammatory damage
or pathogen induced damage.
So just like in humans, in mice
or in any animals that have been studied
all the way back to insects,
when they're ill with acute
infection they stop eating.
This is food consumption in mice
after they received a dose
of listeria infection,
this is a common food
poisoning type of infection.
They stop eating, until they
start clearing infection
and they start recovering and
then they start eating again.
But there is a very profound anorexia
associated with infection,
as you can see here.
So some studies done over 40 years ago
actually found that in the same
model of listeria infection
if mice are force-fed,
then mortality increases.
This is what we reproduce here,
so this is showing survival of mice
that are given LD-50 dose of listeria,
a dose that kills half of mice
and this is what's shown here.
If they are force-fed then all of them die
and they were fed just 20%
of daily caloric intakes,
so they're not really stuffed with food,
they're just given a little bit of food
and that kills them.
The food we used was
actually the same food
that's used in ICU units.
Then we asked what
component of food kills?
So we gave them separately,
proteins, fat and sugar
and turns out that sugar
alone, or glucose alone,
was sufficient to kill them,
whether it was given orally
or intraperitoneally.
So just giving them a small dose of sugar,
only 2% of normal daily
caloric intake of glucose
was sufficient to kill 100% of mice.
Conversely if we gave
them a glucose inhibitor,
called 2DG, 2-deoxyglucose,
it's a modified form of glucose
that cannot be metabolized, so
it blocks glucose utilization
then 100% of mice would survive.
Importantly this was not
because the immune system
was affected in its ability
to get rid of the pathogen
and it's not because
there was a higher
magnitude of inflammation
because these were not different
between mice given glucose
or not, as you can see here.
So this indicated that
mice survived or died
from this manipulation
because of the effect
on tissue protection,
not on the immune function itself.
So then we ask what would happen
in a more severe condition like sepsis?
Sepsis is the condition when
infection becomes systemic,
when it gets into blood,
in this case it's a bacterial sepsis
that's mimicked by giving mice
this component, an endotoxin LPS.
As you can see here
if mice given LPS, or septic mice,
if they're given food they die
compared to a control
where they're just given saline solution.
Importantly if they're just given sugar
then they all drop dead,
but most excitingly,
if they're just given the simple drug
that blocks glucose utilization,
then 100% of them can
be rescued from sepsis.
Sepsis is a really terrible,
intractable condition
that is still a very common
cause of death in ICUs.
So again, the mortality
or protection from death
in these manipulations
was not dependent on the
degree of inflammation,
as shown here is an example
of a couple of inflammatory mediators.
Again indicating that it was due
to increased tissue protection from damage
caused by severe inflammation
that is associated with sepsis.
Then we asked what would happen
in a different type of infection?
So far it showed you bacterial infection
and bacterial sepsis,
and now we asked what would happen
in influenza virus infection?
So when mice are infected with flu virus,
again, they undergo
this period of anorexia
when they stop eating
until they start recovering
and if they're force-fed
to our great surprise they
actually survive better.
So this now giving almost
lethal dose of flu infection,
most mice die,
but when they're given that food
most of them survived.
Also if they're given glucose
that also provided partial protection
and if they're given 2DG glucose inhibitor
then all of them drop dead,
so it was exact opposite to what happened
in bacterial infection
and bacterial sepsis.
Again the effect of glucose
was not due to its impact
on inflammatory response,
so in viral infections
it's a different type
of inflammatory response
which is dominated by interferons,
shown here, they're the same
and the dose burden of
the virus in the lungs
was also the same, was not different.
Again suggesting the effects
are due to impact on
tolerance to tissue damage.
The data that I'm not gonna show
but summarize here, what we found
is that death from viral inflammation
was associated with
decline in vital functions,
like respirations, blood
pressure and so on,
suggesting that there was a failure
in autonomic control
centers in the brain stem.
If mice are given food or glucose
then these declines in autonomic
functions could be rescued,
if they're given 2d they're enhanced.
In contrast death from bacterial sepsis
was associated with neuronal
damage in the mid-brain area
and it was also,
the death was immediately
preceded by convulsions
and these were blocked by 2DG
and they were enhanced by glucose.
So we did PET scan analysis
and found that glucose utilization
under conditions of bacterial inflammation
versus viral inflammation
was very different
and it segregated exactly
to these two brain areas.
Such that in viral inflammation
it was primarily in brain-stem
and in bacterial inflammation
it was in mid-brain area.
So the increased delivery
of glucose to these areas
related to the impact of glucose
or glucose inhibitors on
the damage to these areas.
Then we asked what is
the mechanism of damage
and what's happening there?
So I will just summarize
that part of the study.
What we found was that in the
case of viral inflammation
what happens with cells that
are infected with the virus,
one of the things that happens
there is a particular type
of cellular stress response
known as unfolded protein response
that has two branches.
One branch tries to adapt
this stress condition
and to resolve it
and if that fails the second
branch would kill the cells
as a second option.
This death from this response
is mediated by this
particular gene called CHOP,
it's a transcription factor.
What is known is that glucose deprivation
can exacerbate unfolded protein response
in this stress response pathway.
So we hypothesized that
that brain-stem area,
the neurons in the brain-stem
for reasons that remain mysterious,
underwent this excessive
unfolded protein response stress
that was ameliorated by glucose
and exacerbated by 2GD.
Then we asked whether this pathway
of cell death or neuronal damage
mediated by this gene is involved?
And for that we asked whether mice
that have a mutation in this gene
whether they would be rescued
from the effect of such
inflammatory manipulation?
And indeed what we found, if
we just look at this blue line,
these are mice that have infection,
that have viral inflammation
and they're given 2GD, they all die.
If they don't have that gene CHOP,
then they all survive.
So the mechanism here
is related to a blockade
of this pathway for neuronal dysfunction.
Finally in the case of sepsis
of bacterial inflammation
fasting metabolism that
protected them from death
was related to the switch
from normal fat metabolism
to a fasted metabolism,
there's a switch to fuels
from glucose to ketones
and that switch was necessary
for mice to survive sepsis
and this is shown here,
that giving glucose blocked transition
to a fasting metabolism
and deletion of the gene
that is responsible for ketone production
made mice susceptible to sepsis.
As I mentioned immediately before death,
mice had convulsions in sepsis,
so what we did in this
final set of experiments,
if we gave the mice anti-epileptic
drugs, or valporic acid,
then we could rescue them from death
even when they're given glucose.
So that indicated that the reason
that that worked is because Valproic acid
unlike this other drug shown here,
which is Keppra, which is
also an anti-convulsion drug,
Valproic acid, one of its mechanisms
is related to the same
effect that ketones have
on a particular class
of enzymes in the cell.
I will summarize it here,
that there are two
different pathways to death
and fasting metabolism
is protective in one case
and detrimental in the other case
and the final implication
for human treatment in ICU
is that all clinical trials done so far
with nutrient manipulation in ICU units
have been done on patients
that have not been separated
based on class of sepsis,
bacterial versus viral,
and the results of
these studies were mixed
and we think that it's because
they were not separated
and they basically
cancelled each other out.
Now we are planning to
conduct a clinical trial
where we'll separate them
based on cause of sepsis.
So this is the summary
and finally this work was done
by three very talented
scientists in the lab,
Harding Luan, Sarah Huen and Andrew Wong
and we had help from
other colleagues at Yale.
Thank you for your attention.
(soft instrumental music)